we're now just a little ways into May so
it's a great time for me to do another
monthly update video from my viewers and
subscribers to tell them about what went
on during April that they might have
missed and what we've got coming up in
the month of May a lot in April and a
lot coming up in this month I always
like to begin by talking about three big
things so here they are big thing number
one webinar and seminars online seminars
on Epictetus dichotomy have control a
really important core stoic concept I'll
talk more about that in the May section
big thing number two is hopefully by the
end of this month we will have a new
course in the reason I own Academy on
Aristotle's categories again I'll talk a
little bit more about that in the May
section the big thing number three is in
some respect to holdover from last month
but it but it's really getting under way
this month and that is in the half hour
hagel project we have now passed a major
milestone we are in the spirit section
of the work and I'll talk about why this
was really big news in a little bit in
the April section so what went on during
the month of April
I actually got quite a lot done but I
also got behind on some things in part
because of three three main things that
happened the last was I spent the last
week of April sick with with a sinus bug
that's been going around this area and I
know some other people who got it and
I'm better now but it really took a lot
out of me I was trying to work while I
had it but I wasn't getting an awful lot
done and that was after I came back from
the st. Anselm conference which I'll
tell you about in a bit but that took a
good block of time and then my kids were
here visiting as well on two separate
occasions and I may plan to get work
done while my kids are here but I often
don't for perfectly understandable
reasons so what
actually did happen well let's talk
about events and talks and that sort of
stuff first we started out with another
one of the installations in the world of
speculative fiction series this time
talking about Anne McCaffrey and her
dragon dragonriders of Pern series it
was really fun to go back to those I
actually enjoyed them more reading them
as an adult than I did as a kid and we
had a great pool of talent discussing
some of the aspects because many of the
people there had read much you know more
into the series than I had myself we did
our half-hour Haegele sessions and even
had a half-hour Haegele party I'll talk
a little bit more about that in a moment
but but I do want to put it out there
that this is all because of my patreon
supporters who have been crowdfunding my
half hour Haegele project which is a
massive project I'll probably put
another video out later on this month
discussing discussing that so keep an
eye out for that I went to the st.
Anselm conference up in st. Anselm
College in Manchester New Hampshire
sponsored by the Institute for Saint
Anselm Studies it was a great time for
me because I have been going there since
2000 as a matter of fact I'll link to a
video that I did about a year and a half
ago I think talking about you know doing
research trips up there so I got to see
a lot of old friends I got to cross
paths with people who had met at other
conferences and I got to meet a few
other new people heard some really
awesome papers not only on st. anthem
but also on other important thinkers
like Augustine Thomas even some
discussion about you know technology and
the singularity going on there
so it was really quite fun and my my
friend and students got to rule II came
up and we did a cool interview video
that I'll talk about in just a few
minutes as well then the week following
that
while I was sick actually our second set
of webinar slash seminars on Aristotle
and friendship and the NIC McCann ethics
great questions from the audience you
can a link to the video from the webinar
so if you miss that you can you can
check it out
and then we have the Mk II that is
Milwaukee stoic fellowship meeting some
new faces some great discussion we were
focusing on some portions of Epictetus
and Caribbean and what what they mean
for us and how we deal with those sorts
of challenges so that was events for the
month I have still been teaching an
online class for mirus that's the world
views and values class by the way here's
a plug if you're interested in taking an
earlier version of that class that
actually has more material but not
through Maris College but rather through
reason I oh you can do so very
inexpensively on our reason I Academy so
I'll put a link to that below did a lot
of philosophical counseling and coaching
quite a few tutorial sessions was a very
busy month in that respect picked up a
few new clients and I was engaged in
some pretty extensive consulting
projects as well and curriculum
development the curriculum development
is the understanding the emotions series
that that priority thinking is bringing
out which is real distinctive to their
approach and the consulting was with a
variety of different organizations and
firms I also did three interviews one
was with stoicism today being
interviewed essentially because I'm
going to be a speaker at the upcoming
stoic on I'm providing a workshop with
Andy Shaka my wife and partner on
dealing with difficult colleagues
difficult people at work so there's an
interview and I'll link to that below
Scott truly like I mentioned drove up
from Boston while I was at
the st. Anselm conference and we had a
really cool interview / conversation
that spanned a lot of different topics
we started out by talking about
Aristotle's rhetoric and its
implications for the music business and
music education and veered into a number
of other topics some of them related to
Aristotle some connected with stoicism
some connected with other things and of
course our shared love for for classic
heavy metal as well and I also did an
interview that finally aired on the life
after pain website having to do with
resources in stoicism for dealing with
chronic pain so you know if that's an
issue for you you might want to check
that interview out did a little bit of
writing for our exes dno ntk not as much
as I would like a little bit in medium
as well which I'm starting to explore
wrote a piece for stoicism today which
was quite well-received towards the end
of the month having to do with living in
accordance with nature and what the
Stoics actually mean by that which turns
out to be something kind of complicated
and a bit of you know update stuff in
the half-hour Haegele blog here and
there so I do want to talk about the
half hour Hagel party that we had this
was an online event - like I said
celebrate moving from the previous
sections of the work into the new
section of the commentary on the spirit
section of the work it is the
phenomenology of spirit so you can get
this is a really central portion of the
work and it's a huge accomplishment to
come this far over 170 videos I've been
working at it for more than three years
now supported like I mentioned by by
patreon backers so you know I'm gonna
put in a plug right now if you if you
think that it's important to do digital
humanities projects and you want to
support one that's going to be around
for quite some time I'm doing these
commentary videos on one
the most difficult works of Western
philosophy Hegel's phenomenology of
spirit tens of thousands of people have
watched these videos and people are
getting a lot of use out of them as a
matter of fact they are now in the
hundreds of thousands of views so you
know if you wanna if you're looking for
something to put a little discretionary
income into helping out I greatly
appreciate it
let's talk now about videos so I did get
my six half-hour hagel videos done for
the month making good progress with
those which I'm quite happy about that's
actually been like the entire year I've
been on track with that put out some
more Aristotle core concept videos on
the categories happy about those as well
and did some videos from event including
the Scott to really interview that you
might want to check out so that is April
now what have we got coming up in the
month of May so a number of events one
of them is actually tonight so you know
if you're in the area and you're seeing
this video come to it it's going to be a
really great talk I've been working on
this for quite a while and I'm very
interested in the topic but but if not
you can of course watch the video and
that is 6:00 p.m. at the Shorewood
Public Library a May 2nd and it is on
Boethius theodoric and the Middle Ages
it's in this Philosopher's in the midst
of history series that I've been doing a
quarterly series at the Shorewood public
library draws quite a few people from
from you know around the area sometimes
some other professors as well and this
is on you know Boethius who we normally
think of as a medieval philosopher but
he's really you know one of these people
who doesn't have any idea that the
Middle Ages are happening because he's
at the beginning of them and he thinks
that he's just in the you know mixed-up
period of late antiquity then on
may 10th which is a Wednesday from 5:00
to 6:00 p.m. Central Time we'll have our
half-hour Haegele QA / discussion time
this is an online session you don't have
to be a patreon supporter to come as a
matter of fact this is one of those
things that's under written by my
patreon supporters for the general
public if you have questions about Hegel
or German idealism or about you know
posta Galleon philosophy or you just
want to chat about Hegel or hear other
people ask questions go ahead and and
come and I'll put a link to that below
on the 11th which is the next day on
Thursday at 7 p.m. the Brookfield Public
Library we are continuing this will be
number 17 I believe in the world of
speculative fiction series this time
we're going to talk about Warson Scott
Card and the Ender game series this is
really a great set of books it's
something that was recommended to me by
some of the other participants and I
hadn't read it and the more that I've
been reading them the more of a deep
appreciation I'm developing for Orson
Scott Card and his grasp of philosophy
and his imagination so that's going to
be a great talk
and then the following week on Tuesday
the 16th at 12 p.m. Central Time we will
have our free 45-minute webinar on
Epictetus and the dichotomy of control a
key stoic idea as many people as want to
participate in that webinar can do so
totally free for the public so if you've
got any questions or you're interested
in this this really important stoic idea
go ahead and sign up for that I'll put
the link I'll put a link to a video
about it below which also talks about
the next thing which is on the 20th
which is a Saturday at 10 o'clock
running till 12 o'clock Central Time and
then four o'clock to six
o'clock p.m. Central Time we will be
having our two-hour seminars online
seminars about the same topic but going
much further into depth and providing a
lot of additional resources to the
participants on Epictetus dichotomy of
control each of those sessions is the
same as the other session that day we're
just offering it at different times and
the reason why we're doing that is
because each of them is capped at 12
participants because we want it to be a
much more intimate experience we try to
keep those as affordable as possible so
enrollment in those is forty-nine
dollars and they're there you know
really going into depth on the thing and
you get a lot of you know one on not one
on one per se but you know I answer
everybody's questions sometimes we even
go over time those if if need be so
those are the events from May when it
comes to classes my merest class is
going to be ending again if you're
interested in taking that class only
with more content than they currently
are getting but not ramires you can take
it through the reason ion Academy and
take it at a significant discount over
what what they're paying for it will
also hopefully be bringing out the
Aristotle categories class in the reason
I own Academy I've learned not to
promise that we definitely will when it
comes to these because there's a lot of
there's a lot of work involved in course
design but I'm close to having the
videos finished for it and I'm going to
be starting building that next week and
if I get ambitious enough I'll also be
bringing out a Cicero stoic paradoxes
class as well but that's if I really
really buckle down you probably will see
a few interviews coming out either this
month or next month I'm doing an
interview with a website called stoic
metal and another one with the stoic
guitarist and I've got a few things that
I've got
get done in terms of we call email
interviews where they send you a bunch
of questions and then they'll you know
put those on the site so those are
interviews as well got a lot of big
consulting projects and curriculum
design projects underway this month a
lot of also a lot of behind the scenes
work for you know modern stoicism slash
stoicism today is we're ramping up
towards eventually stoical on stoical
week and a few other things going on
also the normal work of being an editor
I'm going to try to get more blogging
done this month in interacts with you
know at the K the half hour Hagel blog
I'm hoping to write something in heavy
metal philosopher got a few things I'm
working on for the partially examined
life and policy of truth you might see
me in some other places as well and I'm
working on the stoicism and anger book
the shorter one which is on stoic dog
Mota which is preparatory to the work
that I'm doing for the bigger book that
hopefully I'll bring out this right what
about video stuff I'm going to be
shooting quite a lot of video work so
one thing that I'm doing finally that
I'm getting to now that I've blocked out
the time and I can say I fully
understand the text that the person
wanted me to work with is a commissioned
video which hopefully I'll have done you
know by mid month this is a lot of work
on my part so I don't want to say too
much about it but you'll see it coming
out later this month
I'll be shooting my normal half-hour
Haegele videos six of those this month
all on the spirit section I'll be
shooting Aristotle categories core
concept videos where we're finishing up
with that and then I'll probably be
shooting some videos on Cicero's stoic
paradoxes I think I'll probably put
those in my other channel the history of
philosophy channel and if I get the time
I'm going to finally make good on
shooting the existentialism videos on
sart's play the Flies and if I get again
ambitious enough I may shoot some other
material as well hoping to shoot some
more personal videos but I can't promise
that I'll actually get to those but I
certainly will make a good attempt so
that is what's coming up in May as you
can tell a lot of cool stuff I hope that
you'll join me for the you know free
webinar and consider enrolling in the
seminars I hope that you'll think about
supporting my work on patreon with the
half-hour Haegele project even if you're
not a big fan of Haegele this is a
really great model for online commentary
work and I'd like to see more people
doing this kind of thing and if you're
interested in in bringing me in to do a
talk or a workshop or if you you're
interested in tutoring or philosophical
counseling go to my website reason io
comm or you can email me directly at
Greg at reason il and we will talk about
that uh that that's pretty much all I've
got so have a great month and hopefully
I'll see you either face-to-face or
online either this month or in a month
to come